joining us now White House senior
advisor for strategic communications
Mercedes slap the White House should be
happy that in fact this now will be
investigated but we're still waiting on
the first horowitz a report Inspector
General report and now I understand
that's been delayed it's got to be
frustrating at the White House that the
wheels of justice grind this slowly
Mercedes well I mean clearly what the
president wants is transparency he wants
to make sure that they can look into the
FISA and figure out if there were any
political abuses there's always been
concern about that and I think that
that's what the president's going to be
pushing for I think there was abuses I
think I can be a little more opinionated
than you I think as I said she paid for
it Hillary they never told the FISA
Court that would be deception the FBI is
an obligation to verify it they never
did fusion GPS never did and then
they're leaking phony information
unverified information and they're not
telling the FISA Court judge that they
never checked into it where does the
president stand tonight on the issue of
the military he's our commander in chief
that is his number-one responsibility we
know he had an increase in the the
defense budget I can't think of a more
important issue to national security
than building the wall drug dealers
drugs coming across human trafficking
the possibility that enemies of this
country can cross over well does he have
the ability will he use that that
defense budget money to build that wall
well I think the president is exploring
a variety of options at this point
clearly what we're seeing is that with
the budget money that's been coming in
with the 1.6 billion dollars that was
agreed upon is definitely an investment
a down payment into ensuring that we
have border wall and fencing and new
construction that's critical is that
Henry mentioned there's going to be
places already where they're going to be
repairing this wall from a 12 foot wall
to a 30 foot wall well which will again
make it increasingly difficult to have
illegal immigrants come through our
country secondly also is the part of
technology and and personnel you're
talking about a 10% increase in ice
funding very critical as you see Shaw
and in terms of what we need to be doing
to ensure that our national security is
taken care of and that our emigrate and
that the wall is being built and that is
something and a promise that the
president is keeping all right Mercedes
good to see you he is our commander in
chief this is a national security and
defense of our country no-brainer to me